Hindus make up 81 percent of India's
population while Muslims make up 13% and
Christians just over 2 percent according
to the latest figures available but many
right-wing Hindu nationalists want the
entire country to be Hindu critics say
Hindu nationalism has gotten even bolder
since Prime Minister Narendra Modi came
into power Modi's government is led by
the Bihari Genta party that has deep
Hindu nationalist roots India has a
history of inter-religious violence and
recently there's been a new wave of
attacks on Christians churches have been
vandalized and set on fire many
Christians are saying that Hindu
nationalists are responsible for the
attacks
they've also reportedly conducted mass
conversions of Christians and Muslims to
Hinduism Hindu nationalists say they are
simply bringing them back to their
original religion after centuries of
colonization so what does this mean for
a country whose Constitution defines
itself as a secular nation that
guarantees freedom of religion
you